he's running more to the extreme than Trump
on several issues our military has become
politicized you talk about gender ideology
you talk about things like global warming
that they're somehow concerned and that's not
the military that I served in abortion bans
book bans curriculum bans on the Disney question
and attacking corporations I mean a lot of this
stuff is a turn off to practical conservatives
moderates and independents otherwise known as
all the voters he'll need to win so it's an
odd strategy and that's forgetting that he'll
eventually have to Pivot to a general election
where all of that stuff is wildly unpopular I
just uh I don't know I think it's kind of
a Folly still all of the energy a lot of
the condensed energy in the Republican party is
still with Trump no one is better at being Trump
than Trump and DeSantis doesn't seem to have a
cogent cohesive plan other than to be anti-woke